ونواصل معكم نشرتنا من فرنسا حيث تتواصل
ردود الفعل على اقرار رئيس امران ماكرون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد من خلال الماده
49.000 من الدستور التي تتيح له اقرار اي
مشروع قانون من دون العوده الى الجمعيه
الوطنيه وافاد مراس الجزيره في باريس انه
من المنتظر ان يتقدم حزب التجمع الوطني
اليميني الراديكالي بعريضه حجم الثقه عن
الحكومه وهي ذات الخطوه التي تعتزم القيام
بها مجموعه النواب المستقلين وتشترك فيها
عده احزاب على ان يجري التصويت على
العريضتين يوم الاثنين وكان الاف
الفرنسيين تجمعوا في عده مدن احتجاجا على
اصلاح نظام التقاعد وعلى استخدام الحكومه
للماده الدستوريه المذكوره ورافقت تلك
الاحتجاجات احيانا اعمال عنف وتوترات وفي
هذا السياق اعلن وزير الداخليه اليوم عن
اعتقال
310 اشخاص من جهه اعلنت تنسيق يه النقابات
مواصله التعبئه ضد الاصلاح خلال نهايه
الاسبوع الجاري ودعت الى اضراب عام وتنظيم
مظاهرات يوم الخميس المقبل
[تصفيق]
مباشره الى باريس مع نور الدين بوزيان نور
الدين الى اين تتجه الامور امام ما حصل في
فرنسا
على ما يبدو نحو مزيد من اجراءات الامن
لعلك تشاهد خلفي جلال هذا الجسر هو الذي
يمر من هنا من ساحه الوئام الى مجلس
النواب تلاحظ الاعداد الكبيره من الشاحنات
او المركبات الخاصه للشرطه هذا الجسر كله
الان
سيارات الشرطه مركونه عليه وايضا نحن غير
بعيدين عن المكان الذي كان شهد الليله
الماضيه اعمال عنف في باريس نحن هنا في
ساحه الوئام الكونكورد وتلاحظ ان الامور
الى حد ما عادت بشكل عادي لكن بعض الاثار
لما حدث امس تبدو هنا لم يتم لحد هذه
اللحظه تطهير هذا الشارع منها او هذا
الطريق
نشاهد ايضا هناك ساحه الكونكورد ساحه
الكونكورد مكتوب عليها مثلا هذا الشعار او
هذا هذا المطلب يصحه التعبير
المحتجون كتبوا يا ايها الطفل الملك في
اشاره كما يقولون الى الرئيس الفرنسي
عليك الان ان ترحل
في الاماكن الاخرى لعلك تشاهد بقع سوداء
هناك في مكان كان ورشه وهذا دليل على ان
هناك حدثت عمليه حرق لبعض
اجزاء الورشه التي كانت استغلت امس من قبل
بعض المحتاجين وحولوا ما وجد فيها الى
اشياء والى طوب رشقوا به قوات الامن
الجديد اليوم جلال هو ان وزاره الداخليه
شددت من اجراءات الامن وحتى الوزراء وفق
اكثر من مصدر وزاري هنا طلب منهم الا
يقوموا باي نشاط ميداني خشيه ان يعني
يتعرضوا لاي سوء
على الجبهه الاجتماعيه هناك الان تصعيد
واضح من قبل النقابات تصعيد واضح من قبل
النقبات حيث علمنا هذا الصباح بان نقابه
التعليم دعت المنتسبين اليها الى الاضراب
يوم الاثنين والثلاثاء ويوم الاثنين
والثلاثاء جلال كما تعلم هو بدايه
امتحانات البكالوريا ايضا هناك مرافع
اليوم وايضا
مصافي للوقود قررت وقف العمل اذا النقابات
تذهب باتجاه التصعيد في انتظار ما سيتقرر
في قادم الايام حيث كانت دعت ايضا لمظاهره
يوم الثالث والعشرين من هذا الشهر عموما
كل الامور متجهه الى تلك البنايه وهذا اثر
اخر من المواجهات التي وقعت امس ولم يتم
تطهير هذا المكان منها اقول جلال باختصار
ان الان المعركه السياسيه انتقلنا من
النزاع ربما الاجتماعي المظاهرات الى
المعركه السياسيه هناك في هذه البنايه
مجلس النواب مجلس النواب سيقدم فيه اليوم
على الاقل الحزب اليميني الراديكالي
السحب
بحجم الثقه ولكن التطور اللافت هو ان عدد
كبير من النواب يبدو انهم
ينضمون الى مطلب بسحب الثقه علما بانه على
على هؤلاء ان يجمعوا
وسبعين
صوت لكي تمر هذه
التوصيه بسحب الثقه من الحكومه والتصويت
سيتم يوم الاثنين القادم جلال نور الدين
التطورات في باريس في نشرتنا اللاحقه شكرا
لك حتى الساعه